[Música]
justamente en directo a hoy vamos hasta
la ciudad de los ángeles en eeuu donde
ya lo decíamos inicio la novena cumbre
de las américas con varios países no
invitados que llevaron a otros jefes de
estado a ausentarse de la cita se trata
de un encuentro en el que joe biden
busca reforzar sus alianzas con otros
países de la región abordar el tema
económico tras los años de pandemia y
discutir nuevas y más adecuadas
estrategias para enfrentar la migración
en la región a esta hora conectamos con
natalia cabrera ella es enviada especial
de france 24 natalia usted tiene los
detalles sobre el inicio de esta cumbre
así es valentina de inicio aquí en la
ciudad de los ángeles la novena cumbre
de las américas dio inicio con el foro
de la sociedad civil organizado por la
organización de estados américanos y
contó con la presencia de representantes
precisamente de la sociedad civil que
esperan entregar sus recomendaciones a
los jefes de estado y del gobierno que
sí asisten a esta cumbre para que se
integren a la declaración final como lo
mencionaba hay varios países que no
asistirán a este encuentro en la ciudad
de los ángeles pero estos se dividen
entre los países que fueron invitados y
los que no en primer lugar como también
lo decía en el noticiero están cuba
venezuela y nicaragua que no fueron
invitados por decisión de eeuu que
considera que no cumplen con las
prácticas democráticas
que deberían regir en el continente
luego de esta decisión de eeuu el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador que había pedido repetir en
repetidas oportunidades que fueron
invitados las delegaciones de managua de
nicaragua y de caracas confirmó que no
asistiría él en persona sino que
enviaría al canciller marcelo
en respuesta también a este boicot que
de alguna manera inició el presidente
mexicano se sumaron países como bolivia
que el presidente de luízar se confirmó
que tampoco va a asistir y la presidenta
de honduras xiomara castró que también
va a enviar a su canciller tuvimos la
oportunidad de conversar esta mañana con
el subsecretario de estado para asuntos
del hemisferio de eeuu brian nichols le
preguntamos si estas ausencias
significaban de alguna manera un fracaso
de la cumbre debido a que no estará
méxico un país protagonista en temas
clave que se esperaba solucionar como la
migración y esto fue lo que nos dijo
nosotros valoramos las opiniones del
señor presidente de lópez obrador
sin embargo el tema de las constantes
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
cuba en particular pero también en
nicaragua y venezuela es algo que
preocupa al señor presidente entonces
para la tradición del tema de respetar
los derechos humanos algo importantísimo
para
para nuestro país y para nuestro
precedente
entre los países que sí asistirán está
el primer ministro de canadá yo sin
crudo y los presidentes de chile gabriel
boric y de panamá laurentino cortizo que
precisamente están a punto de aterrizar
aquí en la ciudad de los ángeles y es
por eso que me encuentro en el
aeropuerto de la ciudad natal ya usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación
estaremos muy pendientes de lo que
ocurra en esta segunda jornada mañana en
la cumbre de las américas